بالنسبه للاجواء الاسرائيليه دكتور هلسه
كيف تبدو في الوقت
الحالي اعتقد بان الكل في الداخل
الاسرائيلي يريدها يريد هذه الصفقه لكن لا
احد يجرؤ على ان يعلن عنها صراحه ويتبنى
موقفه من الرغبه فيها صراحه وهذا مرتبط
باعتبارات الحاله الداخليه الاسرائيليه
وحاله الغضب الشديد وحاله التصيد انجاز
التعبير كل منهم يحاول ان يسجل على الاخر
موقفا معينا ولكن في المجمل لا احد ضد ما
يجري اعتقد بان تاخير الاعلان عنها مرتبط
باجراءات شكليه بروتوكوليا تتعلق ب اعلان
الحكومه عن الموافقه ثم التدرج للذهاب الى
ترك المساله امام الجمهور الاسرائيلي
للاعتراض وامام المحكمه العليا ومن ثم
الاعلان صراحه سبق في صفقات سابقه كصف
شليط ان مرت هذه المساله بهذه الاجراءات
ثم يعني تبين بانه كل هذه المساله مرتبطه
ب يعني ترتيبات داخليه اسرائيليه تسمح ل
يعني
تمرير الجوانب القانونيه منها والفنيه
منها ومن ثم يعلن عن هذا الامر في الاطار
العام المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني وصل الى
مرحله يريد انجاز هذه الصفقه وهو يعني ي
دفع هو المجتمع الاسرائيلي بمجمله هو الذي
دفع باتجاه هذه الصفقه الضغوطات التي
مورست على المجتمع الاسرائيلي هي كانت
نتاج ل ارتدادات الميدان الميدان هو الذي
حكم السلوك الذي الاسرائيلي في الميدان
وردات فعل المقاومه وتمنع المقاومه امام
الضغط العسكري الذي جرى امام النار
الاسرائيليه هو الذي اوصل لاسرائيل بانها
لا مناص من الذهاب الى هذه الصفقه وكل
الشعارات الكبيره وكل الات الكبيره التي
اطلقها نتنياهو وحكومته ومستوى السياسي
والعسكري منذ بدايه هذه المواجهه سقطت
وتبين بان اسرائيل مرغمه الى الذهاب الى
هذه الصفقه وستستمر يعني ان شاء الله ان
اعلن عن هذه الصفقه انا اعتقد مع صباح
الغد سيعلن عنها ستذهب الامور باتجاه ال
يعني الترتيبات التدريجيه في ملف الاسراء
واعتقد ان الامور ايضا ذاهبه الى ترتيبات
اخرى في موضوع وقف اطلاق النار وفي موضوع
اكبر من ذلك يتعلق بوضع قطع غزه فيما بعد